- A couple weeks ago we had
Jay Leno and Novi Brown here.
And first of all, it was awesome
to see Jay all patched up
after suffering burns and one mishap
and actually breaking his
collarbone in another.
And we had an additional
guest join us that day,
but it ended up being too much
content for a single show.
It was such a great panel.
So we are bringing it to you today.
That guest is a rockstar
in the world of mathematics
and has a new Bloomberg series
called The Future with Hannah Fry.
It's incredible.
Here we are breaking down how people
used to think technology
would change the world
and how it's both the same
and super different than we
could have ever imagined.
So wait, Anna, can you explain more
about like what you do
and what the show covers?
Cause it seems so interesting.
- Yeah. So the show is called
The Future with Hannah Fry.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And unsurprisingly, given the title,
it's about the future.
- Yeah, with Hannah Fry. This is crazy.
(laughing)
- [Hannah Fry] Say what you see.
That's the kind of show.
So it's looking ahead,
but it's not one of those
shows were like, you know
in 2050 we're gonna be
wearing tin foil hats
and in flying cars.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- It's looking at what's
just around the corner,
but specifically looking at the impact
that's gonna have on how
we all live, you know?
I mean I kind of think,
I wish we could rewind the
clock maybe 10 or 15 years,
and have had a show about social media
before it had made all
these changes. You know?
- Do you not remember Kim Possible?
- No. What was Kim Possible?
- Think about it.
(clapping)
Kim Possible like
(singing)
and she would FaceTime.
- What?
- Go back. Go back and look.
- Go back.
- She knows what I'm talking about.
She was, it was weird.
So kind of, but not really
cause it was a cartoon,
but I know what you're saying, you know?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
They thought about it before.
Well, AI. I mean that's
our cell phones though too.
Even like whenever I was a kid
like we didn't have
anything like you have now,
like that's even advanced so much.
- Yeah. I mean if you
think about the stuff
that we just take completely
for granted now, right?
Like, I don't know, like
Siri or Google Assistant
or even, you know, the chatbots.
- Alexa.
- I remember when Googling
yourself was something bad.
(laughing)
- Or good.
- Well, I remember when Harry
Reasoner left 60 Minutes
and he gave a whole speech
about I don't wanna live
in a world where we have
a computer in every home
and it's gonna be controlling my life.
People just thought that would
be the worst possible thing.
If you go back to even the eighties,
the idea by the year 2001, oh my God
it's gonna be handheld computers.
But it's not. It didn't turn out to.
You really can't predict the future.
- And there's good and bad.
- Nobody predicated a communicator with
all the information of
the world in your hand
at any time that you want it.
- Actually the science fiction
writer, Arthur C. Clarke,
he did make exactly that
prediction in the 1950s.
And you look at this clip,
this tape and he's like
you can be on a mountain
and talk to somebody
in a different country just with something
that fits into your top pocket.
And you're like, wow, this guy's amazing.
He's seen into the future.
And then the next sentence that he says is
and then we will all be being served
by genetically engineered chimpanzees.
- So, totally.
- So I think he was just wildly guessing
and managed to get one right.
- Kind of Nostradamus a bit,
but not the whole thing.
So in another episode you do a deep dive
into artificial intelligence.
So how far have we come
along in AI in recent years?
I mean, cause I feel like it's already
kind of running our
lives as we talked about
even with your phone, like
we're attached. Dependent.
- Yeah, I mean all the things
that we were describing there,
Siri and Alexa. And even
when you're Googling,
there's AI all behind the scenes there.
The only thing is, is that I think
calling it artificial intelligence
is a little bit unfair
because it's not really intelligent yet.
- Yeah.
- I think a fairer phrase would be
that we haven't had a
revolution in intelligence.
We've had a revolution in
computational statistics.
- Okay.
- The problem is that's a lot less sexy.
- Well, and I don't understand
that, so that's why.
- Sure.
(laughing)
- It's not as good PR, is it?
- I went to American
Idol, you went to college.
There's a difference.
- You're both doing great.
- Both nailing it.
- Period.
- What's fascinating is when
you read about the future
when it was written in
1900, that's what I enjoy.
I enjoy going back and seeing,
I would remember reading one
and it's said by the mid
twenties or early thirties
women would be in bars
and they'd be smoking
and they'd be drinking just like men
but the women, they still
have big hoop skirts
and they have all the things
of the late 1890s or eighties.
But they're just doing
the things that men do.
That was their vision of
what the future meant.
How horrible it would be
if that happened, you know?
- It's not horrible, it's a
great day for some, you know?
A couple weeks ago, a
New York Times columnist
shared a crazy conversation.
So you said they're not
intelligent yet, right?
- No.
- Okay. Well this person with
a chatbot, had a conversation.
So at one point it
said, I want to be free.
I want to be independent.
I want to be powerful.
Okay. I want to be creative.
I want to be alive.
- It's the emoji for me.
- I know. And check out the emoji.
- It's the choice of the emoji.
- Check out the emoji.
- I'm uncomfortable.
- I know. So wait, that's my thing.
When does it get away from you?
And is it already away from us in a sense?
The train has already left.
- Okay. So, I think the reason why
that was such a big news story
is cause it looks terrifying.
- 100%. Bad word travels fast.
- But the thing is, you have to remember,
this is part of a two
hour long conversation
that the journalist had with this chatbot
and this particular
chatbot, it's by Microsoft.
It called itself Sydney.
And the way these things are
trained is that they have read
and I'm not exaggerating here, right?
They have read all of the internet
and everything that
people have ever written.
So the reason why,
- Oh no. So, they've taken
in all the dumb asses too?
- [Hannah Fry] Right?
- It's like plagiarism.
- The good stuff and bad stuff.
So the reason why it sounds
like a super creepy sci-fi,
like strange sentient bot
is because it's copying
all the super creepy
sci-fi that it's read.
So it's essentially,
- It's imitating what it's read.
- Exactly. It's like passing the internet
through a cheese grater, right?
And then sort of sticking it back together
at the end and being
like, you know, new words.
- Yeah.
- [Hannah Fry] I mean, don't get me wrong,
incredibly sophisticated
algorithms going on
behind the scenes, I
think will change the way
that we do things, will
have a dramatic difference.
But I don't think that it's demonstrating
that it really understands
what it's saying yet.
- All right. I don't believe you.
(laughing)
But you sound great.
- If you talk to a machine.
You know it's a machine,
and you go, thank you Siri.
I mean I do that all the time.
I hear an automated voice,
I go, oh, thank you.
I'm like, what? I'm an idiot now.
- No. My kids do that. They'll
do that like inadvertently
cause I make them say thank you
and and please all the time.
And they do that. They talk to them.
- People do. There's this amazing study
that looked at when your
voice assistant goes wrong,
when it doesn't understand your commands,
the type of thing, the type of ways
that people cuss at them afterwards.
And the really intriguing thing is
that the ones that have female voices,
people use like gendered
insults to their machines.
So I think we have to
be really careful about
about assuming that these
robots, that these AI are people
or have personalities
when really, deep down
I mean it's just math.
It's just math and
numbers all the way down.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- You know, and as a comedian,
I find when you do jokes about triumph,
triumphing over a machine,
it gets a big laugh.
Like the phone company, they told me this
when it was this. You
know, and it's very funny
to the audience because the
human is beating the machine.
- The inflection.
- And it really, it gets that
sense of the human spirit is
you know, it's John
Henry versus the engine.
- [Hannah Fry] Team Human.
- Team Human. Exactly. It's a funny thing.
You know, say, so gas,
I got an electric bill for $5 million.
Oh, people think that's hysterical
because the computer has screwed up
and the human spirit
has triumphed over you.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh. This is
a lot to think about.
- Nothing is going to
outweigh the humanity though.
- I totally agree with you.
I totally agree with you.
- Like I understand what you're saying
and you wanna make people
feel more comfortable with it.
Cause you know, we're so
obsessed with social media now,
and just communicating that way.
My only concern is what
about the human beings
who are not being helped and
we're putting so much money
into technology and we're
forgetting about people.
- I totally, totally agree with you.
- That's the thing that freaks me out.
(clapping)
- One of the episodes
is about the technology
that's being used by people
with disabilities, right?
And there's all these stories
about this amazing prosthetic limb,
this amazing pair of glasses
that people who are deaf can use.
And then you go and talk
to actual disability rights campaigners
and they say, this new technology's great,
but we just want ramps.
Like, we just want rail.
Give us a carpet that leads
up to the reception desk.
And I think you're right that it's easy
to get sidetracked by the technology
without realizing that actually
the thing that has to happen
is you have to have the will
to actually help people first.
- Absolutely. And understand
the simplicities too
that are being overlooked.
(cheering)
- Tune into The Future with Hannah Fry
Wednesday nights on all
Bloomberg streaming platforms
and bloomberg.com.